well I think that certainly you have to
be able to give children basic rights
you know rights against being subjected
to extreme forms of violence and I think
certainly you know there are triggers
that in certainly in developed countries
that hospitals look for that schools
look for if there appears to have been
you no harm done to it to a child that
can be raised before the authorities and
I think certainly appearance rights have
to be respected too but there has to be
that balance of protecting the child it
all comes down again to what's in the
best interest of the child
now I think the Convention on the Rights
of the Child is really about all
children everywhere number one and
number two the Millennium Development
Goals have many of those goals that are
directed at children children's health
children's education access to water and
sanitation nutrition you know the
measure is the same under 5 mortality
access to children to education you know
access to clean water and sanitation
access to adequate nutrition I mean you
don't measure it differently in one
country versus another the rights don't
change in one country versus another